rasheen
is starting us off this hour in new york
city hi rasheen how are you
hey christian dave good how are you guys
great how can we help
okay so my husband and i we go back and
forth on this what would dave say
so when um covet hit in march we were
on our way to paying off our last
student loan great
so what we did was we stopped paying it
off we just put minimum payments
and we started to take that extra amount
and stash it away so that we had an
emergency fund
good as of now because you were right in
the middle of an emergency right
yeah okay so now it's september we have
three months
savings and we have
which is about sixteen thousand five
hundred wow and we have eleven thousand
one fifty one remaining on our student
loan should we just pay it off
or keep the emergency fund and starting
this month
we can start to attack that last loan
and we should be paid off by
february okay so we teach people
and we did all through covid that when
you're facing an emergency you stop
the baby steps you push pause which is
what you did
you push pause and you pile up cash
hurricane coming at the gulf coast
you push pause and you pile up cash
right when the hurricane is over
or you feel safe as a result of the
hurricane
financially safe then
well and physically safe for that matter
too then you push play again
now if you push play on your baby steps
chris and you had sixteen thousand
dollars in there
and your 11 000 student loan what would
that look like right well it's gonna
look like i know without a shadow of a
doubt however important this emergency
fund is
i mean we just came out of this
situation where you realized hey having
that cushion
that saved you guys didn't it rasheen
yeah
yeah it's just it's peace of mind it
absolutely gave you peace of mind you
slept better you
felt better you knew push come to shove
you have money there
and so now are you asking after learning
what we learned
are you asking that is it okay to use
that emergency fund to pay off the
student loan yeah
are you going to push are you ready to
push play again because enough of the
emergency has passed
right and just going into september and
how they're saying that this winter it
might get worse
it's just like i'm on the cusp i just
want to pay it off but at the same time
why not just start paying that 2000 a
month and just
by february we'll be done with this
we'll be done with baby step two
okay and that we're not gonna do both
we're gonna do one or the other
you're either gonna you're either in an
emergency or you're not
if you are you don't pay anything on the
debt and you keep piling up cash
if you aren't you push play and you pay
off the student loan today
i think your emergency emergency's over
and you're just worried about the future
yeah my husband would agree with you
okay
that's how it feels to me but that's
that that's the question that the two of
you need to decide and i can't decide
that
because new york city is freaking weird
i mean it's a
you guys it looks like a science fiction
movie up there right now
we're we're not in the city we're in
connecticut but the closest metropolitan
area
okay well i mean i don't know how bad
your particular hamlet is in connecticut
but um some of these areas it looks like
there's like
paper rolling dust bowls rolling down
the street uh
that kind of stuff other areas are back
you know our county is
relatively normal right i'm looking at
100 people 50 people sitting in our
lobby right now not one of them's got a
mask on
so that's a relatively normal situation
okay
uh but but in your area you maybe have
people huddling in the corner you know
and they're
all about to die or whatever and i i
don't know you got to decide
that right you got to decide that so and
you can look at the per
the circumstances that you are in and
decide are we
in the middle of the hurricane or has
the hurricane gone
by and they're predicting that there
might be another hurricane
someday which there probably will be if
you live on the gulf coast
some day but that doesn't mean that when
this one's gone you don't go ahead and
push play
on this so that's how this feels to me
but i don't know
are your jobs stable yeah they're stable
i mean
that's the one thing he always says
we've got stable jumps we don't have to
worry about that
dave would say pay it today he's right
that's what dave would say yeah
i would i would do that and i think
you're gonna be fine here's the other
thing okay
you got five thousand dollars left over
and you're adding
three thousand dollars a month because
you don't have any student loan payments
anymore
yes sir so next month you got eight next
month you got eleven
the next month you got fourteen so
you're almost back
you're back at christmas right
but you have to redirect that payment
money
toward the emergency fund you treat your
emergency fund build up as if it was
gazelle intensity just like running off
the debt
so we're ready to push play again which
means we clean out all non-retirement
savings and we pay it on debt
because the emergency has passed you
know what david if your job is in
jeopardy the emergency hasn't passed
that's right you've paused
you know what dave i i feel like a lot
of people are going to fall into this
category of this
this fear mode well turn off a freaking
tv
and then there's that good god well
listen 2020 was you know did you see the
new uh i'm getting one of these
the christmas ornament for this year no
i haven't seen it it's a dumpster on
fire with the year 2020
this is to remember this year the whole
freaking year is a dumpster fire
you know so i'm i'm throwing one
hellacious new year's eve party i'm just
saying
i'm never gonna be so glad to see a
stupid year go in my life
and i'm just hoping that people's brains
will start to grow back
dave we are trying to help them grow
back now listen to me people we've got
three and a half months before 2020
is gone how we finish this year is how
we're gonna start 2021
so we're going to start off strong so if
you're serious out there
i want you to start making different
decisions you can be around stupid
and not catch it right you can you just
can it's like a cold
you just gotta watch it it can't be
around fear though it's more contagious
than coveted
yes it is and really truly and be
careful of the stuff you're telling
yourself
stay around some people that have some
common sense that have some goals
and we can still start to finish this
year strong
yeah we can i won't want him ornaments
though
um i think i may just give everybody one
at ramsey for christmas
do that i think it's a great it's been
the year from hell for everybody
it's unbelievable but yeah it's normal
rasheen uh you know we're all laughing
and cutting up here but it is normal
when you've been through something like
this pandemic culturally
to be gun shy but really what we're
talking about here is
what is your hope factor not
false hope based on logic and your
spiritual faith
and other things what is your hope
factor for the future
mine is very high i have a great hope
factor
and so i'm moving forward with business
decisions here with personal decisions
at home
we're moving forward with generosity
decisions as if we're all gonna be okay
yes because we're all gonna be okay